repeating the same thing over and over
again will never make it true
biden's dhs chief continues to find that
out the hard way
the president could not have been
clearer
in his articulation of this
administration's position
nor could i have been clearer and
continued to be
so which is the border is closed
and this administration administers
and enforces the laws of the united
states of america
the biden administration is saying that
while exclusive new video shows migrants
streaming across the border and running
away from agents and this is disturbing
border patrol
stopped 10 sex offenders over a one week
period
so geraldo i'm going to go to you first
on the icky stuff they've seen a
3 000 the sex offenders yeah they've
seen a 3 166 percent increase in arrests
of
convicted sex offenders this this
included uh people
charged with uh lewd and lascivious acts
with children sexual assaults of
children
um persons under 13 and statutory rape
so these are
they're not these are not the best
people is what we're getting at
to quote uh
i think you i think you're wrong about
that it's uh it's of course interesting
and effective to
uh emphasize these aberrant
uh uh people who come over they should
be crushed
arrested their hands smashed they should
be sent away forever
but that's not the vast majority of
these people running through the bushes
that we all have been seeing thanks to
the uh you know the
the drone footage that we're getting for
the first time it's it's uh
where are they going the vast majority
of americans never
see them why do they never see them
because
they are absorbed into our economy they
are
babysitting they are mowing the lawn
they're
washing the dishes in the restaurant
they're working in the poultry
processing plant and the meat packing
plant
they're going across the border because
american employers
are saying come on we got jobs for you
you see all these help wanted signs
this these people are heading someplace
where they're going to be absorbed
into the fabric of the country the vast
majority of over 11 million are here and
i think that number is way low
i think there's more than that we have
to we have to recognize
that as long as we are pulling giving
them the magnet
come on we'll give you a job they're
going to come
yeah i think i mean geraldo but there's
something called a process
you know you can if you want a process
it doesn't make you anti-immigration
and we do have jobs but if they take the
jobs then the wages will be lower
and then the liberals can't ask for a
higher wage what do you make of this
jesse
yeah you kneecap the minimum wage and it
drives wages down
for hard-working americans i agree i
want an orderly process
right now that's not orderly this guy
myorkis reminds me of the reporter that
stood in front of the burning building
and said this was a peaceful protest
what else is he going to tell us those
people running across no no that's just
the mexican olympic track team they're
just getting ready for the games
i mean he thinks we're stupid right
we're stupid
like if you saw a bar with a hundred
people in it would you say the bar is
closed
no the bar is not closed you have a
bouncer
boot out two people but every two people
he bounces out
four people come back in that's that
close that's happy hour
and then they're saying we won't even
deport you also unless
you're convicted of an aggravated felony
so you can actually
punch me in the face and joe biden won't
deport you
you could get drunk and drive your car
into gutfeld's house
no and they won't deport you yes you
could
graffiti dana's beach house and they
won't deport you there's a whole host of
things that you can do bank fraud
you can steal geraldo's credit card take
out loans
and they won't deport you and you could
probably take out a lot of loans on
geraldo's line of credit
and you're right greg trump was right
remember he said they were letting in
rapists
well just just nab 10 of them yeah right
jesse i actually looked into the laws
and if you punch
jesse waters in the face you get instant
citizenship
that's on the books that's actually on
the books it was introduced
it was introduced over 10 years ago true
yeah that's inciting
you are inciting people now i am so the
uh doctor were there also health
consequences or ramifications to this
uh i doubt that they're we're closely
monitoring
monitoring the covered symptoms and all
the people coming in and
going back well it's a lot more than
just that greg you know i did actually a
lot of my training in arizona and i
worked in the county hospital and i you
know i
helped to care for a lot of illegal
immigrants and yes
in the time of a global pandemic we
don't necessarily want to be bringing
people from different countries that may
be bringing in different variants
but when they cross the all these
deserts they have renal failure cardiac
failure they get very sick
and they come across and they're ill and
they come and they need health care
and you know there is an a parallel
increase in crime when it comes with
illegal immigrant activity but you know
as geraldo did point out a lot of people
are seeking refuge but there is a
process for that and as we're seeing
with the defund police movement
the whole abolish ice movement needs to
take a look at what happened there it
didn't go over well
so we need to enforce more of the
process to get people over safely
you know dan it seems to be the strategy
here
is kind of like to let the american
attention span
simply fatigue the assumption is that
over some
about time we'll just lose interest in
this story uh
summer comes people going and then then
this will just kind of like
continue on and on it reminds me of
portland how like
portland every night it's the same
problem still there i know dan springer
did a report for us the other day and
even though it was breaking news i felt
like i'd seen it 100 times before
because that's
what's been going on every night i also
wonder i haven't actually
don't think i've ever seen a less
effective communicator than secretary
mallorcas i'm not even sure
there's like a real person in there like
the way he talks about it it's like
it sounds robotic and it doesn't sound
like they have any heart in it there's
two possible things are going to happen
on a policy front to keep in mind
on the covet issue president trump had
an executive order that basically said
if you're coming from a country that has
high coveted
cases then you can be out basically
deported right away turned away you're
not allowed to come in
apparently that could go away soon
so there goes another there goes another
tool and the other thing is
i this just broke and i'm working on
getting the details don't have them
exactly here but
when you apply for a green card your
wife did
my husband did right so you have to fill
out all this paperwork to say all of
these things
well in on the form is a thing about
either any past punishments or jail
terms or convictions
or anything like that that helps the
process
be done properly they're about to take
that out
it's crazy so that that wouldn't that
wouldn't even be something that you had
to admit to when you were applying for a
green card
well that's bad news dana i hope you're
wrong
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else